[Musique]
ça
en acceptant de rentrer à la ferme
jo le coq suis madame l'api tu lui
montre le chemin en sautillant de
branche en branche
il reprend sens inverse le chemin qui
mène à la ferme
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
madame pipi c'est bientôt la ferme
etes-vous toujours bien sûr de ce que
vous avancez on ne regrette bien là bas
je ne vais pas aller à la casserole
écoutez jo je vous en prie ne vous
répétez pas tout le temps c'est fatigant
inutile
tout le monde sait que les vieilles
personnes radote mais à ce point là
vieille personne vieilles personnes
je vous en prie madame pis je suis
encore jeune
et puis je vous préviens que la barrière
de la ferme est en terme et ne pourront
jamais entrer mais si je connais un
passage secret mais ce merveilleux vous
savez tout ainsi quand je voudrais faire
une petite escapade dans la forêt je
n'aurai qu'à passer par là qu'il revient
d'appel et le voilà qui pensent déjà aux
escapades
eh bien la voilà votre ferme oh quelle
drôle d'effet
or tout est comme avant il me semble
n'être jamais parti en effet rien n'a
changé à la ferme saisie porte leur gras
aux poules et les canards viennent de la
mare pour manger leur part
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
comme chacun est très occupé par son
dîner personne ne remarque joe qui tout
naturellement reprend sa place et se
mettent à picorer dans la cour la petite
fusée la perçoit
[Musique]
notre vieux joe notre vieux jo il est
revenu à ses mots tout le monde à court
mais oui c'est incroyable quand aux
fermiers ils ne changent pas d'idée
bien sûr comme il n'a jamais bougé d'ici
aussi on compter sur vous pour regarder
les quelque chose à oger bien assez à
faire comme ça le poulailler c'est votre
affaire l'amour chrétien on s'ennuyait
de nous tous savoir où tu étais qui nous
manquait beaucoup
taisez vous ne me posais pas de
questions
à partir d'aujourd'hui l'ordre va régner
dans le poulailler et la grosse
jacquotte la grosse jacob que tel devenu
il ne la poule au pot
voilà ce qui arrive quand on est trop
bavarde elle était bonne au moins aucun
écho n'est parvenue jusqu'à nous
personne n'en a parlé
donc même en poule au pot n était pas
réussi ça ne m'étonne pas
avec son mauvais caractère
[Musique]
c